does anybody else hear drums so I get to
now kick off the big debate about how I
tend to qualify and parse out and
separate the stories that come about in
the tail end of Series three what I mean
by that is I am going to deal with the
last two as a two-parter and deal with
utopia separately even though it's kind
of widely considered to be a three
parter it ends with a to be continued I
don't care I prefer to separate it out
in my mind that I'm gonna talk about it
separately because I can and I'm gonna
before I do though quick message from
the sponsor or at least mention of the
sponsor cuz it's not like they're gonna
come in and talk don't don't go ahead
and skip it it's really quick or at
least I try to keep it quick radio
versus the Martians it's an awesome
podcast hey yeah podcast is free cost
you absolutely nothing but it's really
really great you know you've got time in
your day where you're like god this is
so dull you're driving to work you're
stuck doing the idea who knows what and
you could just help pass the time you
know that podcasts are great for that
and this is a good one Mike Gillis Casey
Dorn and a rotating bullpen of guests
come and they talk about all kinds of
geeky and nerdy things they go on
tangents they'll they will release
episodes that are that are based off
just like one little 20 minute tangent
that they did in a bigger discussion
about something else it's a great show
it's well worth your time and they
support this channel so I definitely
appreciate them plus I like their stuff
even before they started sponsoring me
so there we go now let's talk about
utopia this is an interesting one for me
to revisit especially now because you
know I've listened to a grant it didn't
come out
well after but I've listened to the
first series of the war master the the
Big Finish collection with derek jacobi
voicing the master and if you haven't
seen my review for that i'll link up
there it's really good really good
it's expensive though the box sets are
for those things but oh man it was well
worth it uh and in any case it it gives
me an even greater appreciation for
Derek Jacoby's portrayal as Yana aka the
master spoiler but I mean come on then
it otherwise would have done so let's
talk about this thing it kicks off
interestingly with Captain Jack
barreling to the TARDIS and latching
onto and his very presence rocketing
them to the end of time you know
effectively so the the setting is
visually a little bland but it gets the
job done this is a story about hope
about emotion and about that hope
getting torn away from you
so goddammit
the setting wall nothing special it it
does the job and so much of this like I
kind of forgot how much of this episode
really does hinge on Jacobi specifically
because the doctor is there but the
doctor is pretty reactionary to what's
going on you know he offers to help but
he's just assisting on what Jana is
already doing Yanis pretty much driving
all of it and and chantho like I
couldn't remember if I had liked her or
not I remember kind of thinking like
yeah she's fine but at the same time I
thought about what that whole thing she
does I didn't get annoyed about that and
then I watch it again when no no I
actually didn't she's just really
endearing and really sweet and like
especially the one time Martha gets her
to to say a sentence without starting it
with Chan Andy with though and she does
this wonderful little like just
schoolchild giggle at having done
something really naughty and gotten away
with it it's oh it's really endearing
and and I'm glad she got to avenge
herself that's actually kind of nice
because you know doctor who can have a
high body count the doctor often fails
to save at least some people any given
story so you know her you know get
getting her own justice as it were
that's kind of nice and Martha Martha
doesn't have a ton to do here but you
know I'm not sure there was a way around
that because there's so much focus on
the other stuff because Jack's back so
we got to deal with that and then we've
got Jana going on in the overall
situation we're in Martha does still
have a few highlight moments I mean the
one I just mentioned with chantho that
is a that is a shared moment she has
with Martha so Martha gets a few small
moments like that but she's she's very
much kind of sidelined for this one and
now having Jack back is is well it's
always a fun thing I mentioned this
elsewhere I like Jack Harkness way more
on Doctor Who that I do when Torchwood
he's very mopey into
would whereas he has a much better sense
of adventure
in in his appearances on Doctor Who and
that's captured here would like just the
right amount of melancholy undercurrent
just underneath it whereas I feel on
Torchwood that tends to get overplayed a
bit so if you had been watching
Torchwood this is your explanation for
why Jack doesn't die we get that here
and for my money it tracks and it makes
sense for for what it is that they're
doing and I really love the scene where
Jack is in the room with all the
radiation you know trying to do the last
few things so this rock can take off and
[Music]
dodge well not even dodging the question
just initially ignoring the question
from the doctor when he asked him do you
want to die and Jack doesn't know he
doesn't have an answer for that and he's
kind of scared by the question I really
like that there's a lot of truth in that
moment and the tenant and Harkness work
better together I think that my memory
of them not that I ever thought they
didn't work together but I felt and why
I still feel for the record that
Harkness works a little bit better with
Eccleston because he's more of a
contrast to Eccleston whereas Tennant
himself has a little bit of that
swashbuckle adventure vibe so Jack being
there feels slightly redundant not
excessively though that's really only
when I compare it to the dynamic of
Harkness and Eccleston but let's come
back to Derek Jacobi and Jana he at when
he's playing Jana he captures so much
that the the the weight of somebody who
wants to help is doing everything he can
to help but deep down in his heart of
hearts doesn't think it's gonna work
it's like
it's like when your kid loses something
and they're really upset that they lost
it
and deep down you know you're never
gonna find it
but you still look and you turn the
house upside down and you go through the
car and you go through every bag in
every pocket and deep down you you
you're I mean you're hoping and you're
going through the motions but deep down
you're like it's gone he's got that vibe
and and and it's a good one for him to
have under the circumstances ahem the
situation that he's in so that works
really really well and then of course
his his change I mean I've mentioned
this more than a few times that one
turned to camera just the intensity in
the eyes and that one look after he
opens that watch and then just how
vicious he is how angry he is with
chantho this assistant that like just a
few minutes ago he had said you know she
she won't go to utopia cuz she's she
wants to stay she won't leave me and I
couldn't leave her and you believe him
to just turn like that oh it's it's
scary like legitimately
and the sense of desperation from the
doctor you know realizing that a there's
a Time Lord is still alive and then be
who it is and like 10 gets so much
across you know the the fear the anxiety
the horror the dread the desperation
that please we don't have to do this
anymore
and yeah it it works really well we do
also have the regeneration of the derek
jacobi master into John Simm and I
I don't like John Simms master very much
I understand the idea behind him I
understand that he is poised
more of a direct dark reflection of
tenant and I get that in theory because
the original master Roger Delgado was
poised as a dark reflection of of Jon
Pertwee's third doctor and pretty much
everyone who played the master after was
just doing their version of Delgado's
master so it's not a bad idea to take it
in a distinctly different direction and
to cue that direction off of the doctor
that you're gonna be having the master
face that's on paper this is a good idea
but for me personally it just doesn't
work very well I think it's just them
it's the manic energy levels that really
throw me off because the master has been
a lot of things that a lot of points but
he's never been [ __ ] and I'm just
watching John Simm like jump up and run
around the TARDIS and be like and I'm
like you're you're like a cartoon and it
just doesn't I'm not saying that doctor
who can't have that kind of villain but
that doesn't feel like the master to me
he's he's too chaotic he's not he's not
scheming he's just I don't know there's
something about that high energy just
throws it off for me and I'm sure the
fact that I just used the word he's not
scheming people are gonna go what do you
mean he did this and this this and all
this planning I'm like I'm not saying he
doesn't have schemes I'm saying that the
vibe I get off him is just manic chaos I
don't get a vibe of intelligent planning
off of him which to me makes him feel a
bit less like the master and again I'm
the idea is sound I think just the
degree they took it to with that perform
it just doesn't flow for me and
eventually he works better for me with
some of his later appearances and I'll
get to talk about those eventually but
the this initial turn up I just don't
like him and I'll end up having to talk
about that again when I do the next one
but cuz next to in one cuz I'll tackle
both but and and yeah I like I can't
fully justify doing this on its own as
opposed to you know as a as a overall
three-parter but I don't know there's
just I'll justify it on the basis of it
be half-hour video how about we leave it
at that
so utopia you've seen it what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it tell me how wrong I
am and how dare I denigrate John Sims
master yeah you people have told me that
before you won't be the first so
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons links link to radio versus the
Martians link to the patreon if you
would care to support me I would
appreciate it plus there's other links
besides I wrote a book I'm on social
media blah blah blah blah blah all down
in the description give it a look or
yeah don't you don't have to because at
the end of the day you're the counsel
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]